[Peter] This one was a little tricky, but you should get it if you understand assignment.
The answers are all of them except this one,
and we'll go over each one one by one.
I've initialized their values to represent colors,
but they can be any integer as described in the question.
The first line of code states that a refers to what x refers to,
so let's change that.
The second says that a now refers to what a refers to
plus 1, so now a refers to a new number,
which is the red triangle plus 1.
At the end of these 2 statements, x still equals
what it was originally, and that is the red triangle.
A and x as described refer to initial values.
The first line of code says that a refers to what x refers to,
so as we did in the last problem, we result in that a and x
both refer to the red triangle.
Now x refers to what a refers to.
Well, as you can see, a also refers to the red triangle,
so the result of this is that x still refers to the red triangle,
and since that's what it was initially, the value of x has not yet changed.
In this choice, the value of x changes.
Let's show you why.
The first line of code says that x now refers to what it used to refer to plus 1,
so we're going to create a new value that is the red triangle plus 1
and change what x points to.
The second line says x should now refer to what x refers to.
Well, it doesn't change what it's referring to now,
which is the red triangle plus 1.
The end result is that x does not refer to the red triangle any longer,
which is why it's not the correct choice.
The first choice may be a little bit of Python that you haven't seen before.
What this says is a should equal x,
and x should equal a.
The end result is that x and a swap.
Let's see what that looks like,
and I'll draw this all the way around here.
X and a have swapped values.
X now refers to the green triangle, and a the red triangle.
The second line of code is exactly the same as the first.
It's going to swap them again,
and if you swap 2 things twice,
you get what you had before,
so since x refers to the red triangle still,
it's a correct choice.
In the last choice, we have a third variable x, a z.
We initialize z to the value of x,
which is the red triangle.
We then assign a to what z refers to,
which is also the red triangle.
And lastly, we set x to the value of a.
A refers to the red triangle, so x also refers to the red triangle.
The end result is the value of x hasn't changed.